hello I'm Andrew Garfield I'm Claire Foy
and I'm Andy Serkis the director of the
upcoming film breathe we're excited to
bring you this new trailer it's based on
inspiring true story and it will be in
theaters this October we hope you enjoy
it
she's gorgeous
[Music]
[Applause]
and can't possibly marry him diana he's
basically a stranger source if you don't
have other options the thing is I just
know this is it
now I've got news oh yeah I'm going to
have a baby
[Music]
best news I ever had since I'm proposing
you said yeah
[Music]
Robin breathe you inhale the polio virus
from droplets in the air the result is
you can treat for yourself we really
must leave me it run we can't have this
apparently I can get me out of here no
one with your husband's disability
exists outside a hospital anywhere in
the world
I've just had an idea
it does his breathing for him ever no
stopping you now oh boy alright so while
we hockey or pitiful ain't definitely
blocky
use old dowager's of tough-as-nails what
exactly is it you want from me
well we want more of these chairs for
people like Robin
no one's ever believed as possible to
live as you do Bloody Marys
while we should show them
[Music]
when I first became paralyzed I wanted
to die
but my wife wouldn't let me he told me I
had to live as our son grow up so I went
on living
[Music]
your life is my life we could have
[ __ ] wouldn't that be an adventure
why do you keep your disabled in prison
go back to your patient and set them
free
[Music]
I've accepted the risk of dying I don't
want to just survive
I want to truly live
[Music]